200 years ago, it took 12 days to deliver
a message from New York City to London. 150
years ago the first transatlantic cable transmission
was sent from the Queen of England to the
US President, taking 17 hours. 85 years ago,
telephones became common household fixtures
and 30 years ago the first cell phone was
invented, which weighed as much as an iron,
took 10 hours to charge for a 35 minute conversation,
and cost almost $4000. 20 years ago, the first
text message was sent - a simple ‘Merry
Christmas” - and today more people have
mobile phones than toilets, with around 23
billion text messages being sent per day.
But how the hell do text messages even work?
When you tune a radio to a station, you pick
up the information that is being sent out
via electromagnetic waves at a particular
frequency - in this case they are radio waves.
These waves mostly just pass through our bodies
without interacting at all, but are on the
same spectrum as the visible light we see,
just different in size. Photons with wavelengths
between 400-700 nanometers have the perfect
level of energy to excite the rods and cones
in your eyes, which then transmit signals
to your brain that you interpret as different
colours. But radio waves, which have wavelengths
ranging from 100 microns to 100 kilometers,
are much lower energy and can’t excite your
eyes - so they are invisible to us.
Similar to a radio, your cell phone receives
signals at specific frequencies, but it can
also transmit its own radio waves back to
a network at the same time. The network is
a system of towers, antennas and transmitters
which divide a geographical area into ‘cells’
- hence the term ‘cell phone’. These cells
determine which areas are served by which
towers, though they generally overlap so that
your phone always has a tower to communicate
with.
Feel like your phone battery is losing power
faster than normal? Phones transmit at higher
levels indoors due to building materials,
in rural areas due to greater distance to
the network antennas and when moving at high
speeds, like in a car, due to the frequent
handover between network antennas.
When someone sends you a text, their phone
transmits radio signals, which convey the
identity of both their phone and yours, along
with the content of the message. These signals
are then picked up by the tower closest to
them, which converts the radio waves into
a digital electrical impulse and passes it
along to a hub of the network called a mobile
switching center. If you’re out of range,
or your phone is off, the message is stored
by the mobile switching center for a short
time until you can be located by the network.
The network then figures out which tower you
are closest to and passes the signal there.
Once at the tower nearest you, it’s converted
back to a radio signal that can be picked
up by the antenna in your phone. This all
happens in SECONDS!
Interestingly, traditional SMS text traffic
actually peaked in 2011! Now, most people
send messages via internet services. In fact,
last year ‘WhatsApp’ overtook traditional
SMS as the #1 handler of text messaging, managing
30 billion messages sent each day all over
the world. And if you’re sending those messages
across the world, it’s actually sent via
a giant cable that runs across the ocean floor.
In fact 99% of all international data is sent
via undersea cables.
So what does the future of messaging look
like? We’re currently in the 4th generation
of mobile communication networks, with 5G
on the horizon. And it’s actually been projected
that the technology for phones embedded in
our bodies can be available as soon as 2023.
While only a few decades ago it may have taken
months to send a love letter, in just a few
years you may be able to simply think of your
loved one and send them a message to let them
know you care.
We tackle humanity's new forms of communication
in The Science of Emojis over on AsapTHOUGHT,
how they’re often misinterpreted, and how
to use them properly. Check it out with the
link in the description!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos.